[Applause]
well it's a pleasure to be here I would
like to thank the organizers for
inviting me to talk to you today my talk
is going to be highly non-technical so
I'm not going to refer to Python
I'm not going to refer to our I tend to
be more on our person than a Python
person for that it's going to be mostly
I know I know anyway I prefer Adobe
Illustrator actually that's a wonderful
tool anyway so the talk is not about
tools the talk is about concepts ideas
right what comes before we use any of
those tools and it is a talk of parts
and more in particular about how charts
mislead and over how we mislead
ourselves when we see charts and what we
can do about it
the table your the table that you're
about to see is sort of a trailer for a
book that I'm publishing this year in
the fall of 2019 this is not available
yet right but it's going to be published
by WW Norton which is a general
publisher in the fall this year and the
title is how charts like getting smarter
about visual information which is
basically a book teaching the general
public any sort of reader non-technical
reader how to approach charts graphs
maps etc and how to interpret them
correctly how to avoid the most common
kinds of misunderstandings that we
stumble upon whenever we see a chart so
I'm going to give you sort of a preview
a very quick overview of what those what
those things are a little bit about my
background I am a journalist by training
I have no formal training in statistics
or in data science or even in data
visualization I am self-taught in all
these areas I began my career in Spain
back in 1997 I'm originally from Spain
creating infographics which are
pictorial explanations of information
right an accident happened somewhere and
you do a 3d model describing how the
accident happened and things like that I
used to produce that kind of work and
then later on when I moved to the United
States first and then to Brazil for a
few years I started getting interested
in data science and statistics and more
important color in
data visualization and that's what I
teach at the University of Miami a
little bit about what data visualization
is about that's very very important to
understand in order to understand how
charts lie right so the first thing to
understand about data visualization is
that data visualization is based on the
idea on the notion of visual encoding
when you create a visual a visual
representation of data what you do is to
transform those numbers that you have in
your data set into objects or you map
those numbers onto objects and then and
we usually call those objects geum's in
the language of ggplot and other
software tools that we use right but
then what we do is to very certain
features of those objects in proportion
to the numbers that we're trying to
represent right so if you for example
begin with five or six numbers and you
map those numbers onto several
rectangles and then you vary the length
or the height of those rectangles what
you're creating is a bar graph right if
you map numbers on two axes and your map
then using little dots and then the
method of encoding that you use is the
position of those dots over those two
axes
you will be creating a scatterplot right
so this is the language that we use in
data visualization the language of
geum's and the language of visual
encoding and one thing that we know is
that this language this grammar of
graphics is very very powerful it is
very powerful both for exploring data
and it is also extremely powerful to
describe that data or communicate that
data to others the reason why that
happens is that we human beings have a
very very hard time understanding large
amounts of numbers right so if I show
you that data set over here even if I
describe what these numbers are you will
not be able to extract patterns and
trends from those data right this is a
data set a real data set of global
temperatures from the Year 1000 up to
the year 2000 measured in Celsius
degrees in comparison to the average to
an average of the 20th century the
average temperature between 1961 and
1980
does the reason why you see negative
numbers and positive values below that
average or above that average right now
a data visualization is
means - meaning from data and to answer
questions from those data so if I ask
you if the data set comes back alright
imagine that you have the the data in
front of you if I ask you have global
temperatures increased or decreased in
the past 1,000 years you will unless
that you know the answer to that
question already you will not be able to
answer that question through the data
alone
moreover if I ask you has in the past
global temperatures being higher that
they have been today in the past 1000
years that's a very difficult question
to answer taking a look at the numbers
alone right but when we transform those
numbers into some sort of chart when we
map those numbers onto objects right for
example if we transform those numbers
into some sort of line chart mapping
those numbers onto an object suddenly
the patterns and trends that existed
behind the data become obvious right
this is a very famous very popular and
very influential data visualization
probably one of the most influential
data visualizations created in the 20th
century it is commonly called the hockey
stick chart because it has the shape of
a hockey stick there's an entire book
describing the how these a graphic was
created the title of that book and I'm
going to be recommending tons of books
today the title of that book is the
hockey stick and the climate wars
because after the chart was published it
created a lot of controversy in the
public discussion here in the United
States the chart shows you the data
points are the estimates of temperatures
these are actual these are estimates of
temperatures because obviously we don't
have records of temperatures from the
Year 1000 right so climate scientists
reconstruct those temperatures and those
are the point estimates then we have
actual records of temperatures this is
the red line and then the line that you
have over here or is this moves
basically sort of the average direction
of the data using non-technical language
and the chart also shows you the level
of uncertainty around those data points
basically what we are doing is in a very
small space in a very very small space
we are condensing we are
concisely describing what those
sang-soo's thousands of numbers that we
had before in the data set
reveal they don't reveal that if we
present those numbers alone we only can
see the stories the insights that hid
behind those numbers when we represent
them graphically the power of data
visualization I think explains that is
becoming a language that has been widely
adopted in many different realms
obviously in the realm of data science
statistics the science is in general but
also the realm where I come from the
realm of journalism right if you follow
the New Times The Washington Post the
National Geographic The Wall Street
Journal and many other publications here
in the United States and abroad you may
have observed in the last 10 years or so
that the number of data visualizations
that they publish has increased quite a
lot almost exponentially or has
increased very very much well the reason
why that happens right in a data
visualization appear more in The
Economist or the New York Times and
other publications is that through their
analytics these news organizations are
seen the data visualizations are popular
people really like to see maps and data
charts and data graphs actually some of
the most popular stories ever published
by some of these news organizations are
not written stories are not videos they
are data visualizations the most popular
piece of content ever published by the
New York Times online is a data
visualization a data visualization
commonly called the a dialect map the
title of the of the piece is how you'll
use and you guys talk I'm not going to
show this piece you can go online and
find it but basically what this piece
does is to ask you several questions
about how you pronounce certain things
in English how you say certain things in
English and based on your responses to
the questions that you're asked the map
will show more or less where you
probably leave and apparently if you are
a native English speaker from the United
States once you get to the end of the
questionnaire that the tool presents to
you it the tool will basically pinpoint
exactly where you leave
based on the dialect that you speak this
is the most popular piece of content
ever published by the New York times.com
and it's a data visualization I am a
great believer thanks to this expansion
to this new new golden age of data
visualization that we are seeing not
only in technical fields or in
scientific fields but also in the public
conversation in news publications that
there's a lot of potential there's a lot
of promise in this expansion of data
visualization I'm a great believer in
the fact that data visualizations charts
right I use those two terms
indistinctively data visualizations can
enable conversations when a data
visualization is well-designed well done
honestly design presents good data etc
it can enable meaningful conversations
about important topics but in order for
that to happen that chart also needs to
be well understood so there is a dual
responsibility the relational
responsibility on the part of people who
design charts and present those charts
to the public but there is also a
responsibility on the part of the public
to make the effort to understand those
charts correctly right and to read them
correctly unfortunately throughout my
careers I talking to journalists
designers data scientists etc I have
observed that generally people don't
really understand what charts are about
and how charge should be approached I'm
going to show it to you several
misconceptions that I have heard talk to
me or spoken to me over and over and
over and over again throughout my career
there are three myths that I believe
that we need to abandon when we discuss
data visualizations or charts the first
one is a picture is worth a thousand
words well that's not true and I will
show you how to you later on
visualization is intuitive charts are
intuitive right I take a look at this
chart I understand the story immediately
that is very dangerous and very very
misleading and the last one the data
should speak for itself I don't need
anything else right should see the
numbers I interpret it correctly all
those things or all those sentences are
myths and they are only true if we
append an extension to the
sentences which is a picture's worth a
thousand words visualization can be
intuitive and the data should speak for
itself only if you know how to read it
and the danger is that many many people
that see charts on a regular basis and
that includes people with a technical
background don't know how to read charts
correctly we believe we do because we
think that charts are like illustrations
they're like just pictures right and
they are not right charts visual
arguments in order to be understood
correctly they cannot just be seen they
need to be read right they need to be
right as we read any piece of text so
abandoning these misconceptions is
related to understanding several
challenges are several biases that are
related to how charts are created and
how charts are read the first one is
pattern ect this is a very very
important concept to understand what is
pattern is city but ethnicity basically
means by the way patterns is that is a
term that I borrow from this wonderful
book they believe in brain by Michael
Michael Shermer who is a psychologist
Paterna city basically means that we
human brains have evolved to see
patterns naturally in the real world and
to basically over impose meaning to
those patterns that's a very important
trait it's a trait that we evolved
because it is helpful for survival but
sometimes it can misfire an economist it
can misfire very easily and very very
dangerously sometimes for example take a
look at these charts that you have over
here they're not very beautiful right
let's suppose these are completely you
know meaningless but let's assume that
this is for example I don't know the
unemployment rate of nine different
countries over the years obviously that
employment rate doesn't vary that widely
right but let's suppose that it does
write country one country to country
three country for country five five it's
a turn we have the unemployment rate
over there right now if you take a look
at those charts I can for long for you
know for one minute or two minutes I can
assure you that your brains will start
detecting patterns Oh
the unemployment rate on country one
increase over here it also increased on
country number three you're in country
number four and take a look at that they
very almost the same in these particular
years your brains automatically
unconsciously mr. C will start seeing
connections if you stare at the chart
long enough
unfortunately obviously this is a chart
that I randomly created with a little R
script in order to generate they
generate basically nine random charts
but still even if those patterns that
are that that the chart showed of reveal
are completely random our brains will
start detecting them automatically and
unconsciously why is that dangerous
because of the second challenge
narrative once we detect patterns in the
real world right in data in the data
that we see we will start seeking
explanations for those patterns that we
see in the real world one within defy
those patterns are the meaningful right
even if they are there the random our
brains will automatically and
immediately they start looking for
possible stories to tell
around these data let me show you one of
my favorite examples that comes from my
wonderful book title teaching statistics
a bag of tricks this map over here the
map that map that you have over here
shows the counties in the United States
that have the lowest rates of cancer
death by kidney cancer death rates okay
so basically these counties that
experience the lowest number of cancer
deaths per 100,000 people in the United
States are perfect they are perfectly
mapped over there I'm going to give you
another little piece of information that
some of you may already know all right
which is that most of these counties are
rural counties right once you have those
two pieces of information your brain
immediately will start making up stories
connecting those two facts right low
cancer rates you know rural counties oh
I'm going to verbalize what a normal
human brain will start doing well
perhaps these counties have so such a
low number of cancer you know cancer
cancer deaths because they are rural and
as well as they are rural
probably they have low pollution and we
know that pollution is related to a
higher number of cancers it could also
be
know that people in rural counties eat
better right perhaps if they you know
eat organic they grow food in their
backyards or whatever and they eat
better they your eat organic and we know
that a good diet is also related to
lower rates of cancer or it could be
perhaps that people in rural countries
exercise more right they walk more etc
or perhaps it's because people in rural
counties have closer ties with families
and we know that having good
relationships can also lead to better
health that is not in the chart that is
something that happens here in your
brain one thing that we need to remind
ourselves even people who are well
trained in the statistics is that a
chart shows only what it shows and
nothing else everything else that you
see in the chart is happening here it's
not happening in the chart
moreover right we could apply that
principle if we take a look at the
counties in the United States have the
highest highest rates of deaths or have
a cancer death rate okay and those
counties are all rural what is going on
over here well this has nothing to do
with pollution has nothing to do with
diet has nothing to do with you know
having good relationships with your
neighbors or whatever this is simple
arithmetic right it's simple arithmetic
it's like we know in the statistics that
you know small populations all right or
a small samples very much more randomly
than big populations right either the
way that explain these to kids is that
if you have a county in which only
people the only ten people leave right
and in one decade one of those people
died because of cancer suddenly you have
a a death rate of 10% which is a huge
death rate then in that same County in
the decade after nobody dies of cancer
and suddenly you have a cancer rate of
zero right which is a very low rate of
this right so these huge variation in
small counties is a reason why you see
both rural counties in both these maps
but you made over if you didn't know
about this basic arithmetic fact your
brain will still make up
stories based on these data this is also
related to the idea of a graphic a C
which is a very very strange work
what is it graphically what is the
equivalent of illiterate right grafica C
basically means graphical illiteracy
right graphic a C is a word that I
borrowed from another book written by a
cartographer called mark Momo near the
title of the book is mapping it out in
mapping it out Mon Mounier says that
today in order to be an educated citizen
we need to have much more than literacy
right the ability to read and write
write and I wish that educators will pay
attention to books such as this one
because we also need numeracy and
numerous is not just mathematics and it
is not Justice Statistics and it's not
just data science math numeracy is
basically like a sixth sense in the back
of your brain they'll start ringing when
you see numbers that look a little bit
tedious you don't know why that number
looks dubious but you know this
unconsciously almost things
instinctively that there is something
wrong with those numbers that knew that
numeracy at work and connected to the
idea of numeracy you also have the
notion of graph fricassee which is the
ability to interpret to read and
interpret visual representations of
those numbers
sorry I'm not presenting a while on my
boat it's going away anyway so let me
show you an example of numeracy and he
graphically or in grafica see at work
that's a map that apparently hangs from
the walls of the White House
the moment this is a photograph that was
taken by a reporter right after the 2016
presidential election someone White
House aide was carried carrying a
printed copy and a framed copy of that
Mac - hangs from the walls of the White
House apparently President Trump loves
this map of the 2016 presidential
election and for a while there were news
reports that he had copies of that map
on his desk and he handed out copies to
people who went visit him in the Oval
Office right obviously he's very proud
of his victory and he should be because
he won against all odds as you probably
notice as I explained that before but
just in case the map represents a
Republican vote versus Democratic vote
which areas of the United States voted
more for the Republican candidate and
which areas of the register is voted
more for the Democratic candidate
Hillary Clinton right so president from
was giving these copies of this map to
people who came visit him in the Oval
Office not surprisingly perhaps he has
also tweeted about a map so a while ago
there was an interchange between
President Trump and several supporters
and people who opposed him President
Trump was trying to encourage people in
Texas to participate in the primary
elections in Texas and he tweeted
something like um I want to encourage
all my Texas friends to participate in
the primary elections and someone who
opposes president Trump replied to
presenter I'm saying you have no friends
and someone someone who supports
president Trump replied to this other
person saying really do you think that
we have no friends take a look at this
map implying
take a look at the amount of red on that
map versus the amount of blue on that
map right a president Trump retweeted
this person saying such a beautiful map
thank you well the map is the map is
very beautiful I love maps but I also
believe that that particular map if you
don't know how to read it correctly
right can be really really misleading
regardless of whether you're a
Republican or a Democrat these works
both ways by bike ways by the way the
map has also appeared
on book covers there was a book that was
published an e-book published right
after the elections called citizens for
Trump written by an author called Jack
push a biack and when I saw it I you
know I I tried to be nice to people and
when I saw it on social media and I love
maps and I loved charts right I love you
know giving feedback about charts when I
saw people promoting this book in social
media I reply to people particularly
episodic saying I'm not going to quote
myself verbatim here but the the what at
this period what I said was I think that
you either need to change the title of
the book or to change the illustration
on the cover because the title doesn't
describe what the map is showing at the
map doesn't show what the title says
right because your title is citizens for
Trump and the map is not showing
citizens the map is showing something
completely different so I'm I'm aware
that changing HR maybe a little bit to
this we could so perhaps what you may
want to do is to change the title of
your book to something that better
describes what the map is really showing
remember the whole idea behind data
visualization the idea behind data
visualization is the representation of
numbers through the proportional
variation of a certain feature of a
certain object if you want to title your
book citizens for Clinton or citizens
for Trump it doesn't really matter you
should not use that map because the
amount of red and the amount of blue is
not proportional to the number of people
who voted for trauma who voted for
Clinton right what is the proportion of
red and the proportion of blue on that
map is 80% red and 20% blue and there
isn't wider and that obviously
indirectly gives the idea of a victory
by a landslide probably does a reason
why president Trump likes this map so
much right but the map is very
misleading very misleading so the
problem with this map obviously is that
and that the reason why there is so much
right on the map is that there are huge
huge swathes of territory in the United
States particularly maseeh in this area
over here that are basically devoid of
population very little people live there
in the Midwest in the middle of the
country basically a
of mine who's a cartographer can feel
created an alternative map in which he
tried to pinpoint every single voter in
the election and then he color-coded the
voters according to whether they vote a
Republican or a Democrat and then try to
geolocate each one of them close to the
places where they leave right and
there's a result and you can see again
no like huge areas over here that are
completely empty all right people in
this era stand to concentrate in the big
in the big cities right well I'm not as
sophisticated as Ken but if I needed to
you know write a book title citizens for
Clinton or citizens for traffic and it
doesn't really matter I want to use a
map right I wouldn't use a map what I
would do would be to use a chart that
shows the number of citizens who voted
for each one of the candidates
perhaps in a simple bar graph will show
these data right because they we here we
have basically the ID the election was a
50/50 50/50 split food is at forty six
percent four percent one forty eight
percent for candidate Clinton right
that's the real number of citizens who
voted for each one of the candidate but
even this chart is very misleading
because if you want to talk if you want
to title your book citizens for Clinton
or citizens for Trump that graphic is
not enough why because not all citizens
voted in the election if you want to
title your book citizens for Clinton you
need to show me all citizens who could
have voted now the problem is though
that the largest group of voters in the
United States if the people is the
people who didn't even vote and when you
take that into account well perhaps you
will not want to title your book
citizens for Clinton or citizens for
Trump you will need to title your book
citizens for nobody because that's
basically the largest group of voters
and by the way by the way let's suppose
that you win a presidential election for
some reason you run for office and you
win a presidential election which one of
these you will post on the walls of your
White House well I can tell you if I
ever win a presidential election myself
something that is not possible because
I'm not American right I will be a
naturalized citizen but I cannot run for
president I can run for Congress but not
for president anyway so that's probably
a plan
for the future but anyway so but let's
suppose just for the sake of argument
that I win a presidential election right
and I want to celebrate my victory when
I use that map over here to celebrate my
victory now because that map and this is
related to the work that you do doesn't
display the metric that really matters
to win a presidential election United
States that metric is not the popular
vote it is not the amount of territory
that you control right this is not you
know world Warcraft or whatever right
that doesn't really matter what really
matters is the amount of electoral votes
that you get right so perhaps the
graphic that should be printed out and
posted on the walls of the White House
should be a combination of charts that
show the electoral vote right how many
electoral votes president from God or
myself if I ever went to the run for
president right president song got many
more electoral votes than candidate
Clinton then perhaps a map that shows
the electoral vote at the national level
and then perhaps also some sort of
cartogram a cartogram is a map that
distorts the areas of a region according
to another metric right in that case
it's a map that destroys the states of
the United States according to the
number of electoral votes that they
contribute to a presidential election
the challenge number four is the fear of
complexity this is a very very dangerous
one we in the world that I come from the
world of journalism this is a very very
important topic that I discuss all the
time because we journalists tend to over
simplify things and this happens also by
the way not only journals I have also
observed observed it happening also in
data science and in data analytics right
we have this huge data set and we try to
convey what the data set is saying or
the stories of the data set through an
average for example well somehow
sometimes the average is a good
representation of the entire data set
but sometimes an average can be
extremely extremely misleading right let
me show you a chart this chart over here
there is nothing wrong with it it's
perfectly fine it's a chart based on the
best available data that we have showing
the murder rate per 100,000 people in
the
United States and we all know the story
right murder rate increased during the
80s came down during the 90s and then
stayed morally more or less the same
during the 2000s and then in the past
two or three years the murder rate has
started increasing again this is the
kind of important conversation that we
need to have what can we do about that
right and charts can help a lot with
that to inform public conversations but
only if we design them correctly and
only if we interpret them correctly and
this chart is very often misinterpreted
because indirectly it tells you the
story that the United States is becoming
a more dangerous country right and that
is not true absolutely not true what is
the problem with this average nor really
an average but let's call it an average
this rate right what is the problem with
these well the problem is outliers right
most places in the United States right
if you go to my neighborhood here in
Miami I live in Kendall there has been
one murder in the past six years or
something that I just want in the past
six years so if I could plot my own
neighborhood in 2015 by the way we could
extend this line and it will keep
increasing but let's suppose that I
could plot my neighborhood over here it
will be down here probably because the
murder rate in my neighborhood is really
really small right and most places in
the United States are down there if we
could plot every city or every time
United States the murder rate is very
very low I lived in Brazil that's murder
rate right so whenever I see this kind
of discussion in the user and people use
only this chart I feel compelled to say
you cannot just show the national
average you need to discuss the role of
our outliers what is the challenge right
that even if most places in the United
States are quite safe right there are
outliers right there are certain
neighborhoods in big cities and
mid-sized middle sized cities there are
so dangerous I have become so dangerous
in the past four or five years that they
basically distort the national rate
according to crime statistics we know
much more than I do about these but I
have read articles about it and they say
you know if you could plot those places
in this chart they will go through the
roof it will be impossible to put them
on this scale because the murder rate is
so enormous and those outliers
basically as in any kind of data set
that contains huge outliers they work as
magnets right you have your line and you
have the magnet over here and suddenly
you're like start spiking up just
because of the role of those our lives
the way that I usually explain these to
journalists and graphic designers the
world that I come from is that if you
show only the national rate you are
misinforming people you need to show
them the national rate the average so to
speak but also you need to explain those
outliers to me so I can understand what
is going on and then we can have an
informed conversation about how to solve
this problem because this is a real
problem number five we are getting there
these are seven challenges number five
is confirmation right once we have seen
patterns once we have found explanations
to those patterns right we don't want to
see those explanations disconfirm or
refuted we hate that right there is a
bias a very well-known cognitive bias
that many books describe called the
confirmation bias right once we form an
opinion right forming opinions is much
easier to abandon in opinions where we
don't like abandoning opinions and that
is the really dangerous particularly if
those opinions are part of our
ideological overview or a logical stand
to stance to where the world if you're
interested in learning more about the
confirmation bias there are many books
about a tons of them my favorite one is
mistake mistakes were made but not by me
by Carl Travis and earlier Aronson this
is a wonderful book about cognitive bias
is the best one that I have read even
better than thinking about fast and slow
and many others although that's another
wonderful book this is my favorite one
right now let me show you an example of
confirmation bias how easy it is to see
a pattern jump to conclusions and then I
stick to those conclusions right and
what we can do to abandon those
conclusions a while ago I saw a
discussion in social media about whether
Obamacare the Affordable Care Act is
good or bad for the job market I don't
have an opinion about that I'm not an
economist I'm not qualified to cast an
opinion right what I do know a little
bit about these charts though and I saw
several commentators using the following
chart to defend and defend the idea that
Obamacare is great for the job market
because if you take a look
the number of jobs created in the
private sector in the past few years we
all know this curve right the curve will
map right then the economic crisis came
and then you know the number of jobs
created by the by the private market
went down very sharply and then we have
the recovery around 2010 and the number
of jobs created in the job mark in the
private job market is started increasing
again and it keeps increasing which is
great news right there our employment
rate in the United States right now is
really really low it's a historical low
levels and then they say well you know
Obamacare is not bad for the job market
because take a look at what happens very
close to the place where the curve
changes direction Obamacare was passed
implying well Obamacare actually helps
with their recovery well no a chart
shows only what it shows and nothing
else the mantra that we need to repeat
ourselves over and over again because
otherwise our brains unconsciously will
jump to conclusions you see two events
happening simultaneously or one after
the other are very close to each other
in time and your brain automatically
makes the causal connection between the
two we it could have been that Obamacare
is great for the job market
I don't know right or it could be we
could find we could look for alternative
explanations to these changes of the
curve it could be you know that
President Obama's stimulus package which
which passes passed over here those
billions of dollars that were injected
in the in the private market they
started affecting the economy over here
and then private companies a study
started hiring workers again that's a
possible alternative explanation again I
cannot claim that I know about that but
it's a possible alternative explanation
what I'm getting at is that whenever we
see charts we need to control our brains
not to jump to conclusions and to think
about alternative explanations that we
could pursue or that we could explore
further or or think about
counterfactuals what would have happened
if Obamacare was never passed what about
is Obamacare got killed I don't know by
the Supreme Court for example how would
that curve look like I don't know it
could have looked like that right a more
rapid recovery I don't know or it could
have looked like that or I confirming
the idea that Obamacare is good for the
job market
if the curve has loot has looked like
that we don't know because a chart shows
only what it shows only what it shows
number six I'm getting to the most
important ones I think rationalization
there is an increasing amount of
literature about the difference between
reasoning and rationalization those are
two things that are related to each
other but they are very different there
are very very different the difference
is that it described in this book over
here the book is titled the Enigma of
reasoned enigma reason and what the
nygma reason and other many books
similar to this one although this is my
favorite one say is that human
intelligence didn't evolve to discover
reality a series that's what not human
intelligence evolved for humans in human
intelligence have evolved to justify our
own opinion to ourselves and then
justify our own opinions to others so we
could persuade those others to join our
tribe to join our group and to create
sort of a commonality of opinion against
the other outside the group that's what
human intelligence apparently evolved
for according to evolved for according
to the theory but these kinds of
researchers explained in books such as
this one why is this so important
because this is also related to the
previous charge that I show you before
it is important again because we tend to
jump to conclusions we tend to stick to
those conclusions and then we tend to
resign ourselves into reinforcing those
conclusions let's suppose for example
that you are a cigarette smoker I'm not
a cigarette smoker but let's suppose
that I am right and I hear people
telling me over and over again you
should stop smoking the smoke is not
good for you you know it's going to kill
you in the long term I'm getting there
it's going to billion long term blah
blah blah but I want to keep smoking
just because I like smoking I want my
opinion confirm well I'm going to show
myself a chart that will confirm my idea
that cigarette smoking is not that bad
for me right it's a chart that shows you
that I would have actually cigarette
smoking is great for your health there
is a positive relationship between
cigarette smoking per capita
and life expectancy country-by-country
if you create a scatterplot of cigarette
consumption per capita and then a GDP
per capita n-- see in years per person
right you will see that well the
relationship is not linear obviously
will be better described as a curve
right but it's a positive relationship
right the more cigarettes people consume
the more life expectancy people have
that's how people interpret this chart
but it is not the right way to verbalize
what this chart is showing this chair is
not showing that the more people smoke
cigarettes the more they leave what it
is showing is that at a national level
there is a positive relationship between
cigarette smoking and life expectancy
period that's what the chart is showing
now why is this happening well it is
happening because of several biases and
several you know paradoxes that are very
common in statistics the first one is
the ecological fallacy
I made an individual conjecture and I
got an individual inside something that
applies to me based on data at the
national level
that's the ecological fallacy right you
cannot make an inference about a lower
level of aggregation based on data at a
different level of aggregation if you
want to make inferences at the
individual level you need to get
individual data not national level data
and the second one related to that as I
mentioned before is I'm going to get to
what this means a we also need to be
careful with amalgamation paradoxes or
more commonly known Simpsons paradox
which is our relationship that you see a
relationship that you see at a certain
level of aggregation may be more vague
or may disappear once you get to get to
a different level of aggregation and it
may even reverse this is a great example
of an amalgamation paradox because once
we start disaggregating the data by
income level for example which is what I
was doing over here the relationship
disappears right there is no positive
relationship it's almost random
relationship between one variable and
the other variable if we disaggregate
the data even more at the regional level
at the local level etc the relationship
pretty sure will start you know flipping
right once we get to the individual
level person-by-person
we could plot that through a survival
rate chart right and we know that
survival rates of people tend to be
higher if we don't smoke right and if we
smoke cigarettes in particular our life
expectancy is going to be substantially
lower at the individual level right at
the individual level finally finally the
c-7 challenge is what I would like to
call moral blindness what is moral
blindness what moral blindness is that
for some reason in the past few years
many many people we are all in social
media etc Berg for example I'm in social
media for sure but for some reason we
tend to believe that or we dislike when
we are called out about our
responsibility about this the
information that we spread publicly
among our our our our networks for
example many of the chart that I show
you before I have seen them retweeted
for example mindlessly write I for
example I know I'm from Europe so I tend
to like the idea of Obamacare right so
if I see a chart that shows that
Obamacare is great for the job market
I feel prompted to I will feel prompted
to retweet it mindlessly oh this chart
confirms what I already believe I will
retweet it that's what most of us do
right we need to stop doing that because
we all have a moral responsibility to
improve the public conversation and that
involves controlling our impulses to
spread information that we don't double
check ourselves a little bit or that we
don't think about a little bit a little
bit carefully in the past few years by
the way there has been an increasing
number of books related to what I would
like to call a sort of a revolution in
public understanding of numbers right if
you take a look at that for example this
slide I'm showing six books favorites of
mine about thinking about numbers for
the general public these are basically
several books done well I included my
own book over here right but you know
let's focus on these ones over here so
negative statistics about science how
not to be wrong those are popular
science books that are intended to teach
the public the general public how to
think critically about numbers and I
believe that that's fantastic that's
really really great what I miss in those
books though is two different things
one is that they usually don't address
charts which is an inch or a gap that
I'm planning to fill with this new book
that I'm publishing in the fall but
second of all second of all they really
don't aggress the address this ethical
or moral component of how we are all
responsible for the information that we
put out and I believe that is really
important why because charts and as an
extension of charts statistics and as an
extension of Statistics science or
decide the methods of science in general
those are tools they're cognitive tools
that we have developed to make us
smarter to extend our own brains our own
cognitive capacities we have designed
those tools in order to do that in one
sense they are not different to a hammer
a hammer is also a tool that we have
created to make us stronger to extend
our own arms and to make us those arms
is stronger and to have an ethical
dimension there is an ethical component
we need to think about the consequences
of the tools that we put out or the
consequences of the information that we
put out because in the same way that a
hammer can be used to build things right
charts and statistics they can be used
to build understanding or to enable
conversations but the exact same hammer
cut or the exact same chart or the exact
same techniques that we use to create
charts and statistics they can also be
used to destroy that same understanding
or to hinder the conversations the very
important conversations that we need to
have in the future about important
issues so we are all responsible I think
for creating a better informational
environment if you're a specialist a
scientist a data scientist etcetera you
should read a little bit about ethics
it's very important to read a little bit
about philosophy ethics etc and ethical
behavior practical ethics right Google
practical ethics so many very good books
about that practical ethics second of
all if you are not on a special is you
also have a responsibility if you're
part of the public right well if you are
a designer a statistician a scientist
specialist you always they have the
moral mandate I would say to just
publish good information to just publish
charts that you have assess
you have double check that you have
verified etc but I was saying even if
you're not a specialist a char creator
even if you are just a reader of charts
or a reader of numbers we also as
readers have also responsibility readers
the general public and this is a message
that a hammer over and over again in the
new book readers in general also have
the responsibility to curb our own
impulses to retweet or to post in social
media or to send to friends and family
things that confirm our own ideological
positions before very fine weather the
things that we are sending are actually
trustworthy or not thank you so much
before I by the way before I finish
these I asked for permission for the
organizers to do these to make a little
plug for a conference at Morgan I think
if you're interested in interested in
computation I guess that you all are
there is a conference coming up in um in
February in early February February
first a second called computation and
journalism so this is going to be a
small gathering of computer scientists
programmers statisticians etc on one
hand and journalists who work for places
such as the New York Times The
Washington Post etcetera and many other
news outlets to have a conversation
about important issues how artificial
intelligence is going to change the
world the way that we communicate how
predictive forecasting affects
participation in elections for example
there is going to there's going to be a
talk about that how data visualization
can be better created etc and so on and
so forth so if your entities in all
these issues please go to that website
and sign up for the conference I will be
happy to see you there and please you
know talk to me you are if you attempt a
the conference anyway thank you so much
it was a pleasure to talk to you today
all right we've got time for one
question I see a hand up let's make it a
good one Thank You excellent talk so one
reason a data visualization can be
misleading is because the author of the
data visualization makes it that way to
make some point that the author wants to
make on the other hand the author of the
visualization can just do a poor job and
it's it's the person interpreting the
visualization that is comes to the wrong
place do you have any insight on which
is more common in practice and then I
don't have data to back me up on these
it's an intuition but I think that is
Paul go ahead you're interrupted oh I
had another question very easy question
you had a cool spotlight tool what
instead of a corner what is that let me
address a larger question first so this
is I mean where did I leave it
this is called the log E or logy I don't
know how to pronounce it logic logic ted
logitech yeah it's a logitech i don't
know i got this other day in BestBuy and
it's super cool I like it I feel like a
Jedi you know working with my anyway um
so talking about the the first question
that you had so I think that is more
common to see chars that are created
with the best intentions and they are
they're well designed there is nothing
wrong with the murder right chart that I
showed you right it's only that you need
to have some prior knowledge of the data
in order to understand that chart
correctly so it's like a there's a dual
responsibility there's a shared
responsibility between the designer and
the reader the responsibility of the
designer is to show the data as best as
possible and to show a sufficient amount
of data right so showing just a murder
rate alone the national level that's not
a sufficient amount of data you need to
show more but even if I if after showing
a sufficient amount of data people
misinterpret that chart is usually
because they don't pay attention to the
chart and one of the things that I that
I usually do in public talks and in the
new book is I said is that I said the
first rule of before becoming a good
chart reader is pay attention I don't
assume that you can understand a chart
by taking a quick look at it because a
chart is like a piece of text in order
to understand and you cannot just
look at it you need to read it and you
need to take a look at the source and
you take a look at the scales and the
legend or whatever in order to interpret
that correctly so there's also a
responsibility on the part of readers to
become smarter right there's a wonderful
I don't remember the the reference for
these but I recently read about a
philosopher that said who said that we
all have the responsibility to become
smarter right to try to become smarter
in order to participate in for
conversations so again it's a dual
responsibility the designer has more
responsibility obviously but there's
also has more responsibility on the part
of the reader do you get well thank you
again thank you
[Applause]